we both started on Idol yes and I have
no idea until literally last night that
one of your audition songs was since
you've been gone
yes oh my god I didn't know that yes um
well oh well thank you no I remember
auditioning you know there's so many
different rounds before you even get so
you even get to Paul Iranian summon
which we have the original three oh my
god gosh I don't for nobody does it I
actually auditioned with the sweetest
thing I guess Newton yeah went through
to the next round and then saying that
one again and I thought maybe this will
be good keep doing this one and I think
it was Paula had asked me to sing
something could you sing something pop
and I went I just started singing your
song no way and I was terrified because
you picked us that would not be my go-to
first person that came to mine and then
20 seconds of something else and so I
think broken wing by Martina oh good
song do the same thing like I did luck
charm for me it got me through to the
next round that's awesome they had all
of us do that though everybody thinks
it's like one song I just sing like
three different one again yeah I was
like am I still proving that I can sing
on key here like this is amazing
backstage dish we are spilling the tea
everywhere I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this